[Musique]
isabelle linars bonjour bonjour merci
d'être sur le plateau tv soixante dix
huit pour un vide qui vous est
entièrement consacré vous êtes ici parce
que vous êtes à la fois versaillaise
vous êtes actrice vous êtes auteur et
vous avez une compagnie qui est alors
pas en résidence comme on dit déjà base
est basé c'est ça pour alors votre
compagnie et balisé sur verse à
versailles et elle s'appelle les
turbulentes et vous avez une création en
ce moment qui est en train de se faire
donc une pièce qui va s'appeler dites
moi comment va s'appeler vote billy
survivante des survivantes voilà donc
tout ça nous amène à parler de vous
alors on va démarrer par le débutant
qu'à faire isabelle inapte donc vous
êtes vous avez fait des études de
théâtre
racontez-moi un peu votre parcours eh
bien j'ai commencé cours florent comme
beaucoup et puis très vite je suis
rentrée au conservatoire de paris
voilà la cncd conservatoire supérieur
d'art dramatique paris j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir michel bouquet marcel bluwal et
pierre de bouche comme professeur à mal
et voilà un petit peu antoine vitez
aussi rapidement et puis wollerau puis
après je suis rentré dans la vie active
du théâtre des grêlons vous étiez plutôt
consacrer au théâtre
oui ce qui ne m'a pas empêché de faire
du cinéma et la télévision
il la télévision en fait on peut dire
que vous avez un peu alterner les trois
oui tout le temps tout au long de votre
carrière
oui oui voilà et alors ce côté auteurs
justement et metteur en scène c'est
nouveau ça existait déjà vous avez déjà
écrit des pièces racontez moi oui j'ai
écrit des pièces en face ça m'est venu
parce que j'ai commencé un petit peu à
réécrire comme ici par ci par là sur des
tournages réécrire ça veut dire quoi
oui mais c'est à dire que parfois on
vous donne
vous avez des rôles et puis par on
commence à dire tiens
en bouche c'est pas tout à fait ça
peut-être qu'on pourrait le dialogue
nécessiterait des petits rangements
malins et ça a commencé comme ça donc on
vous confier la tâche de me confier la
tâche on apprécier la tâche et puis ça
m'a donné envie j'ai toujours eu envie
d'écrire un cela dit j'ai toujours écrit
mais là ça m'a donné confiance en fait
c'est une question de confiance
oui et oui ça me voilà pour vous aviez
le résultat tout de suite fait on ce que
vous écriviez et eddy mis en bouche tout
de suite oui oui mais ça a marché ou pas
wii wii fit seraient tous soulagés ou
surtout c'est j'avais l'approbation si
des scénarii oui voilà ça marchait voilà
et c'est là que je me suis dit bon et
une carte à jouer
il ya une carte à gégé a écrit voilà
j'ai réécrit aussi un scénario
entièrement et qui a été
acheté par france 2 c'était quoi ça
s'appelait le marathon du lit eux
enfin j'ai coécrit en fait à une bruno
gantillon et j'ai signé les dialogues
bruno gantillon quittons un réalisateur
oui oui j'ai beaucoup travaillé vrai que
j'apprécie énormément
ça fait mal et voilà donc on a travaillé
ensemble et et puis j'ai commencé à
écrire d'accord dont il avait plusieurs
cordes avatar alors racontez moi cette
volonté donc de créer une compagnie
c'était y'a combien de temps les
survivantes et jetant les gants
c'est pas les survivantes c'est la pire
tuerie de nantes mais j'ai fait c'est
tuer une femme
une turbulence voilà ils ce sont des
femmes qui sont
qui sont avec moi dans cette compagnie
vole le logo la apparaître à l'écran a
dit moi donc ça existe depuis quand
alors les turbulentes elle existe depuis
trois ans je dirais seconde près basé à
versailles comme on l'est l'asie et
alors quelques ce que vous avez à votre
actif comme avec les turbulents oui vous
démarrez julio des matériaux témoigne
émergentes
on démarre on a on démarre avec les
survivantes les survivants c'est une
thèse là on va parler voilà quoi la
circulation qui est en création au
théâtre 13 oui on a on a fait une
résidence
il ya là on voit une photo qui est prise
pendant une répétition j'imagine voilà
oui mais ça crie ça réussit c'est une
répétition sont deux actrices jj2 dron
et amel sharif d'accord et alors on va
en revenir plus en détail sur cette
pièce donc et survivantes voilà que vous
avez co écrit avec blandine et ayez
c'est ça voilà alors de quoi est-ce que
ça par les survivantes là en fait c'est
une pièce qui est à partir de
témoignages de prostituées qui se sont
réinsérés dans la vie qui elles sont
réinsérés où il pratique quasi
pratiquement tous oui d'accord il
précède témoignages allant viennent de
vous enfin comme la réserve indienne de
elles viennent d'une association qui
s'appelle le mouvement du nid bons qui
sont d'ailleurs nos partenaires et
[Musique]
ce patient des partenaires ou
coproducteur
mais c'est au choix aux ja et est en
fait sont des témoignages au départ dont
je connaissais rien du tout un immense
de monde et c'est blandine métayer qui
m'a mis en contact avec ces témoignages
du mouvement du nid et qui m'a demandé
d'écrire
voilà si tout à coup je me sentais
d'écrire sur ces témoignages et
finalement j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant arrière que vient de
prostituées de femmes qui jouent le rôle
de prostituée dans la pièce il y a cinq
femmes et un homme d'accord les cinq
femmes donc sont des prostituées qui se
sont réinsérés on est d'accord oui qui
vont se réinsérer les sauces sur le
chemin de la réalisation voilà je
comprends elle est là elle se sont pas
encore réinsérer enfin dans la pièce
histoire la dramaturgie en gros c'est
que y'a l'une d'entre elles va les
persuader de sortir de cet état que
c'est pas joli prendre la parole et de
parler et de sortir de cette honte qui
est la prostitution en fait à leurs yeux
pardon alors j'ai eu moi j'aime et j'ai
postulé passé s'est-il laissé cette île
à l'heure du fcl the spy tenter le
palace est beaucoup plus à faire oublier
qu'on savait ce que ça oui parce que en
fait elles sont dans un système qui fait
que de toute façon elle honte parce
qu'elles n'ont pas la parole on les sait
que c'est vrai enfin il ya encore il ya
beaucoup de fantasmes c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs parce que nous on le
rencontre il ya beau y entre c'est quand
c'est encore un tabou très fort il ya
beaucoup de projections sur sur ce
qu'elles sont sur ce qu'elle devrait
être
on se fait de vous une image bien sûr
cette pièce elle est là pour ça
d'ailleurs l'entrée la vérité oui la
vérité vraie et se dire que ça pourrait
être soit quoi la façon dont elles dont
elle arrive elle arrive à cette
prostitution
oui parce que moi c'est ce qui m'a fait
écrire c'est que je me suis complètement
identifiée alors c'est à dire je me suis
pas dit comment
non je me sens faire une chose pareille
et en faire une chose pareille je vais
lui dire bah tiens ça aurait pu être moi
d'accord oui alors justement sur votre
travail d'écriture
vous avez créé donc cinq personnages de
femmes
est ce que ce sont cinq histoires
vraiment distinctes où vous avez pris un
peu de tous les témoignages pour faire
cinq personnages ces cinq personnages
oui j'ai pris plusieurs j'ai pris
plusieurs histoires pour créer des
personnages d'accord et est-ce que vous
avez juste pour la petite histoire
garder quelques fois des phrases intact
ou d bien sûr j'aimerais bien sûr et je
me suis inspiré surtout de leurs deux
situations qu'elles ont vécu oui ça on
ne peut pas d'inventer non j'suis magie
non non non surtout qu'elles sont
parfois truculentes parce que c'est un
spectacle n'est pas du tout la glauque
pas du tout ni tristes non non c'est pas
du tout c'est fort ouais mais elles sont
très vivantes elles ont beaucoup de
personnalités chacune elles sont drôles
parfois oui oui vraiment cet humour qui
est quand même inhérents là ces
personnes alors oui oui et
et puis il ya une certaine poésie aussi
dans ce spectacle d'accord je l' ai
voulu comme ça s'il n'est pas du tout
mal aux cons de mourir on ne montre mais
on ne démontre pas déjà on n'est pas du
tout donneur de leçons non plus
puisqu'on ne prend pas du tout le public
en août à chasser une chose dans une
horreur il n'y a aucune agressivité et
d'aller au voyeurisme non plus mais ayez
et vous dites que le spectacle est
ouvert aux n'est pas interdit aux moins
de 12 ans c'est à partir de 12 ans on
peut aller quoi c'est pas joli façon il
était logique parce que j'y passe pas
violence et en ce moment non c'est fort
c'est à dire qu'il ya des mots parfois
qu'ils sont un petit peu cru mais ça
n'est pas glauque
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est à
dire que c'est beaucoup moins glauque et
tout ce qu'on voit à la télévision par
moments où c'est beaucoup moins choquant
d'accord il ya un décalage qu'il ya
plein de choses qui sont décalées dans
ce dans ce spectacle et tout laisse tout
ce qui pourrait être tout ce qui
pourrait paraître justement un peu
glauque
j'ai choisi le parti pris de les décaler
pour les faire passer donc on n'est pas
le temps et pas forcément présent jma
quoi je crois d'ailleurs la lumière joue
un grand rôle
oui bien sûr l'ingénieur du jeu de
lumière là oui bien sûr et oui c'est pas
c'est pas il ya des moments d'ailleurs
c'est pas toujours réalistes on est dans
des espaces temps différent
il ya du champ il ya du rap voilà pour
la musique et la musique beaucoup
d'effets spéciaux si enfin on est et on
a choisi un une c'est nous qui n'est pas
réaliste justement d'accord voilà des
bords de cette eau n'est pas seulement
du trottoir non non non non on est dans
une station service désaffectée mais qui
pourrait être presque un square enfin on
sait pas très bien on est resté le lieu
quand même du combat de ces cinq car sa
sueur pour se vêtir assurent de leur
situation prix assure on a là on à la
fin elles s'en sortent elles se savent
pas on le dit pas l'homme qui joue avec
vous quel est son rôle
alors lui il incarne plusieurs
personnages en fait ils incarnent saint
côme le père prostitueurs au départ et
après il va il va être à la fois le
client le mac est le marin parce qu'on
en termine quand même sur une note
plutôt positive et on n'a pas voilà
c'est pas non plus on n'est pas c'est
pas le procès des hommes 1
et justement pour ça on a voulu
terminer avec ce marin qui finalement a
compris leur combat et va lutter avec
elle a bien un allié un allié très bien
ok et dites-moi la prostitution
aujourd'hui vous j'imagine que vous
savez ce qu'il en est ce que c'est de
pire en pire est ce que ça change
d'aspect par rapport il écrit que c'est
sérieux mais oui c'est palier de pire en
pire pour les femmes sont plus en plus
jeunes les enfants autrement elles sont
de plus en plus jeunes elles sont deux
avec l'immigration
des peuples c'est une catastrophe
il ya un esclavage sexuel il ya un
trafic de femmes qui est hallucinant
alors ça c'est une partie de la
prostitution qui est dramatique bien
évidemment et puis il ya aussi tout ce
qui est dérivé c'est-à-dire tout ce
qu'on peut voir maintenant sur les
réseaux sociaux les enfants c'est pour
ça que je trouve ça intéressant que les
quelques les jeunes viennent voir parce
qu'ils ont une fausse idée d'ailleurs
c'est assez rigolo quand on a fait la
présentation du spectacle au théâtre 13
juste avant nous il y avait le génie
grandet et après les survivantes et il y
avait dit ribéry met donc deux collèges
étaient là avec deux de ses élèves et
elle est venue me voir après la
présentation de dix ans ils ont coché
les survivantes est ce que vous croyez
qu'ils peuvent venir voir cette pièce de
théâtre et j'ai dit bah oui oui moi je
pense qu'au contraire c'est pédagogique
parce que il ya vraiment des choses qui
se passent maintenant dans les cours
d'école qui sont dramatiques travail bon
ben écoutez on va venir vous voir max
bernier plaisir est lui même très envie
donc théâtre 13 bonne répétition vous
allez jouer à partir du 3 mars jusqu'au
5 avril
et voilà merci isabelle l'ena merci à
vous mon courage et merci beaucoup à
bientôt à bientôt enfin
[Musique]